في فوكيت قبالة سواحل
تايلاند ، تمحو الأمواج التي تتصاعد بسلام
على قناع الشاطئ
بشراسة إذا كان لدينا
لقاح سيكون خبرًا رائعًا للغاية ، ونأمل
في
ورقة العمل إذا كان اللقاح على ما يرام ،
نأمل أن يعود هذا العميل ،
فاللقاحات هي  أفضل حل الآن
عادة ما يكون صاخبًا في هذا الوقت من العام
، حيث تُركت واحدة من أفضل الوجهات في العالم
بسبب الوباء ، وكلما أسرعت فوكيت في الوصول
إلى مناعة القطيع
، كلما استطاعت أن تستقبل
هؤلاء المسافرين الأثرياء من الخارج ،
ويعتمد حوالي 85 في المائة من السكان
على السياحة.  بشكل أو بآخر
سواء كانوا يعملون في الفنادق أو
صيادي سيارات الأجرة ، كل ذلك مرتبط بالسياحة
بالنسبة لفنسنت جيرارد الذي يدير محمية الأفيال في فوكيت
الوباء ، وكانت
قواعد الحجر الصحي الصارمة للحكومة التايلاندية
تشكل تهديدًا وجوديًا
للأعمال التجارية.  شركة ، لذلك
نحن لسنا مؤسسة ، لذا
قبل kovit ، سيكون مصدر الدخل الرئيسي لدينا
هو
الزوار الذين يأتون إلى هنا ويو  في جولاتنا
، غادر أكثر من 150 فيلًا يعيشون في فوكيت
الجزيرة منذ بداية covet
لأن المعسكرات اضطرت إلى
إغلاق
الحجر الصحي بشكل مؤقت أو دائم للأجانب ، مما
ساعد تايلاند على السيطرة على انتشار
الطمع 19.
توفي أقل من 100 شخص بسبب
فيروس كورونا هنا يقول
أنتوني لارك ، رئيس جمعية فنادق فوكيت ،
إن الانخفاض الناتج في السياحة قد
تسبب في أضرار لا توصف
ونعلم أن الفيروس ليس ما
يدمر
هذه الصناعة ، بل هو الحجر الصحي
والآثار المتتالية تتجاوز
هذه الجزيرة فقط
حيث أن العديد من العاملين في مجال السياحة  يأتون من
خارج فوكيت
ويرسلون دخلهم إلى أوطانهم
لإعالة أسرهم
بعد عام من النضال ، يعلق الكثيرون هنا
آمالهم على خطة حكومية
جديدة للسماح
للأجانب الملقحين بالبدء في العودة
إلى الجزيرة في
يوليو وتخطي قبرة الحجر الصحي تقول ذلك
المخرج من هذه الأزمة
ليس بالسياح
المحصنين بل تطعيم السكان
المحليين بحقيقة الخوف  أو هنا مرتفع جدًا ، فأنت
تعلم أن هناك الكثير من الأشخاص في تايلاند
لا يريدون أن يأتي الأجانب إلى
هنا
مع هذا أنت تعرف أنه
يحمل الفيروس ، لذا فإن السر يكمن
في تطعيم المجتمع المحلي إلى
مستوى نشعر فيه بالأمان  بما يكفي
مع وجود الأجسام المضادة
وأنظمة الناس للترحيب بالسياح مرة أخرى
دون الخوف من
حصول دولة نامية مثل تايلاند
على جرعات من اللقاح لم يكن سهلاً
، فقد تلقت البلاد ما يزيد قليلاً عن
مليون جرعة حتى الآن
لسكان يقارب 70 مليون نسمة
مع الملايين  المزيد من الجرعات حسب الطلب
قالت الحكومة إنها ستعطي الأولوية
لفوكيت التي تعتمد على السياحة وتخصص
ما يقرب من مليون
جرعة للجزيرة على أمل تسريع الطريق
إلى مناعة القطيع يبتسم جيرارد في
فكرة بلوغ فوكيت هذا المعلم البارز.
في
نهاية النفق ، يتطلع إلى الترحيب
مرة أخرى بالسياح الدوليين الذين
يدعمون الأفيال الـ 12
إلى جانب العديد من الحافلات الأخرى  نيسيس في
قلب صناعة السياحة في تايلاند
بليك إسيج سي إن إن